the opening scene features a woman named
Cecilia Cass who wakes in the middle of
a night beside her boyfriend Adrien
Griffin a wealthy Optics engineer and
businessman Cecilia turns out to be in a
violent and controlling relationship and
has been for a long time unable to
tolerate it any longer she finally
decides to break free from his highly
secured house for this she first
administers a dose of diazapam to Adrien
retrieves her already prepared bag and
sneaks out of the Mansion all while
monitoring him via CCTV on her phone
before leaving the premises she releases
their dog Zeus from its shot caller but
it accidentally sets off the car's alarm
waking Adrien up diazapam be damn du as
a result she jumps off the wall and runs
towards the highway there she is picked
up by her younger sister Emily who seems
to be puzzled moments later a furious
Adrien comes running comes out of
nowhere and demands that they open the
door he even smashes the car window but
the sisters managed to to drive away
just in time the scene then fast
forwards to 2 weeks later and we learn
that Cecilia has been staying in the
home of her childhood friend detective
James lener and his teenage daughter
Sydney despite james' efforts to ensure
her safety Cecilia remains reclusive and
fears to set foot outside the house even
Random Encounters like a passing jogger
startler one day Cecilia freaks out when
Emily comes to visit her because she
believes that Adrien knows where she
lives and might have followed her here
however Emily asserts that she doesn't
have to be scared anymore as Adrien has
committed the unthinkable Cecilia sits
in shock and takes some time to process
the news she then finally confides in
Emily and James about how abusive and
controlling Adrien was toward her she
mentions that he wanted a baby but
knowing that it would only make her
Escape impossible she continued taking
birth control pills the next day Cecilia
receives a letter from Tom Adrienne's
brother and lawyer he summons her to his
office to fulfill his brother 's final
wish Cecilia visits him with Emily and
learns that Adrien has left her a $5
million fortune and an estate with this
money Cecilia gifts James with a new
ladder to paint his house cheap gift and
also gets Sydney admitted to her dream
College okay that's better as a form of
gratitude at night Cecilia feels
somewhat uneasy sensing that she has
being watched and stalked by an unseen
Force she looks around the house but
finds no one as she walks outside in the
cold we see someone's breath beside her
in the morning Cecilia is seen making
breakfast in the kitchen as she walks
away for a brief moment the knife moves
mysteriously and the burner
automatically turns on to the highest
temperature igniting igniting a fire
seeing this Cecilia and Sydney hurriedly
grab an extinguisher and managed to put
out the fire these incidents prove the
presence of some unseen force in the
house gu naked somewhere in the middle
of the night Cecilia is sleeping next to
Sydney when the blanket is slowly pulled
off and several flashes of light are
seen as if someone is clicking some
photographs Cecilia wakes up and tries
to retrieve the blanket but it won't
move she then notices what look like
Footprints standing on the covers and
slowly moving toward her this freaks her
out so she screams loudly waking up
James and Sydney she claims that someone
is in the room but the other two find
nothing a Miss James then assures her
she is just traumatized and paranoid so
she should take some rest the message
being that she's a woman after all and
no one is going to listen the following
day Cecilia goes to a job interview for
an architect's position there she tries
to present her work portfolio contents
but finds her bag completely empty she
suddenly starts feeling dizzy and
collapses to the ground she is then
rushed to the hospital where she gets
her blood work done Upon returning home
she receives a call from the doctor
telling about high levels of diazapam
found found in her system and that's
what caused her to faint to her horror
she finds the same bottle of bloodied
diazapam in her bathroom with which she
drugged Adrien during her Escape feeling
unsafe Cecilia accompanied by James goes
to meet with Tom she believes that
Adrien faked his death and used his
Optics expertise to become invisible in
order to torment her she also recounts a
chilling past incident when she was
planning her Escape in her mind but much
to her shock he continued to stare at
her and claimed that she can't escape
from him at any cost however Tom rebuffs
her idea since he has an earn with
Adrian's ashes he also presents her with
crime scene photos to confirm that
Adrien indeed committed the unthinkable
after this Cecilia goes to talk to Emily
who is surprisingly angry with her
having received a hateful email from her
account confused Cecilia insists that
she didn't send it and that Adrien is
doing all of this however her sister
does not believe her her claim and shuts
the door on her back home Cecilia checks
her email and discovers the message sent
from her account causing her to have an
emotional breakdown and the acting is
really good a short while later Sydney
walks in and tries to cheer her up right
then an unseen Force strikes Sydney in
the face making her think that Cecilia
did it terrified the girl screams and
summons her Father James is enraged at
Cecilia but he decides to take his
daughter out of the house to a safer
place at first now that she is alone at
the house Cecilia tries various tactics
to catch the Unseen figure whom she
believes is Adrien she spills coffee
grounds on the floor and stays in the
bedroom waiting for him she should have
said Marco not long after she tries to
call adrien's cell phone and hears it
vibrating in the Attic climbing up she
finds her work portfolio and Adrienne's
phone with several photos of her asleep
at the same time she receives a text
message saying surprise in a state of
panic she dumps a bucket of paint down
the attic trapo and it surprisingly
coats the invisible figure ooh my
favorite color you remembered babe after
making her way back downstairs she hears
the kitchen sink running upon heading to
check she discovers that the figure has
washed the paint off as if it's that
easy in a self-defense move she grabs a
knife but she is soon grabbed by the
neck and thrown across the room a
violent struggle ensues but Cecilia
somehow manages to escape from the house
she hurriedly grabs in Uber and heads to
Adrian's Mansion near a Sea Coast upon
arrival she makes her way to adrianne's
research lab in the basement there she
discovers a high-tech bodysuit covered
with cameras that can turn invisible
which finally confirms her suspicions
Cecilia takes this suit and hides it in
their former bedroom's closet as she
prepares to walk out she sees another
pair of invisible footprints that
attacks her again shortly after their
dog intervenes buying her time to flee
the scene we may be invisible raggy but
I know an [__] when I smell
one Cecilia then sets up a meeting with
Emily at a restaurant and apologizes
while also explaining that she loves her
Emily's skepticism starts to melt as
they begin to bond after which Cecilia
proceeds to disclose about the invisible
suit at Adrienne's lab just then in a
moment of eerie quiet The Invisible Man
slits Emily's throat and places the
knife in Cecilia's hand framing her for
murder in the after maath a shocked
Cecilia is arrested and moved to a
sanitarium she continues to scream that
Adrien killed her sister until she is
strapped down and sedated afterwards
Cecilia is tested and interrogated for
allegedly killing Emily in defense she
tries to explain herself but she senses
Adrian's presence in the room and
hesitates to do so while awaiting trial
Cecilia is remanded to a psychiatric
hospital where she learns an astonishing
Revelation she is pregnant she's going
going to give birth to a little
Invisible Baby a few days later Tom
comes to visit her and offers to get her
charges dropped on one condition give
birth to the baby and return it to
Adrien here it is revealed that Tom
helped stage his brother's death and was
working with him the whole time he
further discloses that Adrien knew that
she was taking birth control pills so he
swapped them with something else which
is how she got pregnant Tom also says
that she will lose the fortune and will
be admitted permanently to this
institution if she doesn't accept the
deal however Cecilia who is still
devastated by her sister's death turns
him down she throws Tom's belongings off
the table giving her a chance to steal
one of his quill pant her master plan is
to pretend that she's like Shakespeare
later in her room Cecilia prepares to
commit the unthinkable with the same pen
Oh that's oh but the Invisible Man stops
her turns out this was bait and Cecilia
uses this opportunity to stab him with
the pen this causes his suit to glitch
and for him to appear and disappear at
random just then a patrolling guard
walks inside only to be stunned by the
glitching figure who then beats him down
Cecilia tries to run as more guards come
but the Invisible Man incapacitates them
all before escaping into the stormy
night Cecilia follows him to the parking
lot where she confronts him in order to
protect her unborn child the invisible
figure instead threatens to attack those
she loves starting with Sydney soon as
the figure departs Cecilia calls James
and warns him of the danger she also
grabs a car and races to his house
meanwhile The Invisible Man arrives and
starts to attack Sydney James rushes to
the scene but the figure subdues him as
well not long after Cecilia breaks in
and sprays him with the fire
extinguisher revealing his shape and
what a stupid shape it is she then
shoots the figure four times finally
resulting in his demise as she unmasks
him she is sh shocked to see that it's
Tom seriously why the hell did this guy
want to help his brother do this in the
meantime a SWAT team storms Adrian's
house and finds him alive tied up and
claiming that Tom held him prisoner in
the aftermath of these events James
explains to Cecilia that the evidence
suggests that Tom used his brother to
get to her however she is still
convinced that Adrien and Tom were
working together and that when things
went wrong Adrien set his brother up as
the scapegoat for his crimes in order to
get Adrian's confession Cecilia goes to
meet him at his house secretly wearing a
listening device while James positions
himself a few blocks away and EES drops
on their conversation they sit at a
dining table in full view of the
security camera she agrees to mend their
relationship but only if he confesses
that he was The Mastermind behind all of
this Adrien insists that Tom was
responsible and claims that this
experience changed his outlook on life
and how he treated her after Adrien says
the word surprise Cecilia excuses uses
herself and heads to the washroom he
always used to say that word she thinks
his favorite word in all the land
meanwhile Adrien senses something a miss
when his head is suddenly jerked back
and his throat is slashed as a result he
collapses to the ground and starts
bleeding heavily Cecilia returns to the
dining room and appears shocked she
instantly calls the police reporting an
apparent self- kill in a panicky tone
out of the camera's sight however she
coldly stares at A Dying Adrien and
taunts him indicating that she had used
the spare bodysuit to kill him she then
walks away from the scene leaving him to
die on the floor James who hears the
commotion rushes in and stumbles upon
Cecilia walking out with a Fearless
expression on her face she asserts that
Adrien committed the unthinkable but he
soon spots the suit and realizes that
she did it despite this realization
James appears to have no choice but to
believe in her story and let her go
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching